Two decades of civil war.
No government.
A haven for international piracy.
A militant uprising
and a million refugees.
Somalia has long-been the international
model of a failed state.
A new president was elected a year ago
and his government's influence
is starting to take root.
It's trying to move this impoverished
nation from an emergency
to a recovery phase.
But Somalia's challenges,
like its social structure,
are complex and varied.
That's where the EU,
through its comprehensive approach
to the Horn of Africa,
wants to play a role.
With three missions, political support
and more than a billion euros
in assistance,
the EU is trying to help get Somalia
back on the road to recovery.
Security is the biggest challenge.
So building up the army
is a high priority.
It's a big task, that Europe is tackling
through its military training mission,
EUTM Somalia.
The presence of EUTM Somalia
in Mogadishu
is most certainly an accelerator as far
as the European Union is concerned,
establishing
an expanding future foothold
in Mogadishu
and throughout Somalia.
It will be able to provide
situational awareness,
provide logistical support,
force protection support,
to ensure that all of the requirements
for a secure deployment
of the full spectrum of EU actors,
both in Mogadishu
and throughout Somalia, is in place.
To help Somalia defend itself,
EUTM has moved into the Jazeera camp
in Mogadishu.
For the last 3 years
the mission has trained
some 3,000 Somali soldiers and officers
remotely, in Uganda.
Trainees will now be lodged here,
in some of the camp's 130 buildings.
As part of the comprehensive
European approach to state-building,
EUTM staff also advise
the defence ministry
and the EU funds
the African peacekeeping force here.
Work at Jazeera goes on,
bolstering the camp's perimeter,
with sand bags and watch towers.
The chief security threat in Somalia
comes from Al-Shebab,
a hard-line Islamist group
linked to al-Qaeda.
Fighters routinely launch attacks
in Mogadishu,
to show that they can strike
anywhere, anytime.
Much of the European Union's political
capital goes into supporting this man,
President Hassan Sheikh Mohamud.
This flight offshore
to meet EU commanders
came the day after
an Al-Shebab attempt on his life.
The president has been in office a year
and is working to project his influence
throughout Somalia.
The New Deal conference
in Brussels in September,
which secured new funds
and international support,
is set to help his government
restore stability.
The counter-piracy operation,
EU Naval Force Atalanta,
is currently run from
the Dutch ship Johan De Witt.
It's a huge floating dock,
capable of launching fast boats
to chase down pirate skiffs.
The Force watches over
one of the world's major shipping areas.
In fact, we have four tasks.
First of all, we protect
World Food Programme ships.
We deter and suppress piracy.
We protect vulnerable shipping.
And we contribute to
the monitoring of fishing activities
off the coast of Somalia.
The biggest challenge
is the amount of water
because the size of the area we are
patrolling here is the size of Europe.
The EU NAVFOR Operation commander has
no doubts about the value of the operation.
Europe relies on the trade that goes
through the Bab-el-Mandeb straits.
5,000 ships a month pass through there.
I should think 80 per cent of that,
on their way north through there
and up to Suez,
is going to conduct trade with Europe.
If we don't have confidence
in that route
then, all of a sudden,
one of our key interests is affected.
International efforts at sea,
the robust patrolling by warships
combined with the work of private
security firms on cargo vessels,
have helped to thwart the pirates.
But much work remains to be done on land
to provide jobless Somalis
with other opportunities.
What we know is that we have
brought piracy down by 90 per cent.
That's a great statistic.
But actually
things haven't changed ashore.
The networks are still in place
and if we take the pressure off
there's no reason why piracy won't
re-emerge as a difficult issue for us.
So we've got to stay here
until the seas are controlled.
Given Somalia's security challenges,
ships like the Johan De Witt are also
being used as floating classrooms,
to help tackle the problems of piracy
closer to the shore.
In the safety of these vessels,
the EUCAP Nestor mission
is helping to build up the coastguard.
Staff train police and customs officers,
in an effort to contain the problem
before any would-be pirates
make it out to international waters.
In the Somali basin
EU Naval Force personnel head out
to round up suspects
and question boat owners.
They build up a database of information
that will help identify repeat offenders
and pinpoint the source of
the piracy problem.
In an exercise on deck,
Somalia's top justice officials
are taught about European
evidence gathering techniques.
This is knowledge they can use
to collect, handle and process
materials found at
a potential crime scene.
It's expertise they can use
when pirates face them in court.
Our job is to gather evidence
and to deliver it to a court
and they will decide.
It's just one part of
EUCAP Nestor's work,
but it's all part of shifting the focus
from piracy at sea back to the land,
where extremes of poverty,
climate and ideology
created the problem in the first place.
Our success with piracy,
and the changes in Somalia
with the federal Somali government,
mean that there's space and time now
to look at this problem ashore.
The roots of the piracy problem
lie ashore, the symptoms lie at sea.
So we need to really get to
the heart of this disease.
And at the heart of this disease
lie problems of unemployment,
particularly among young men.
Many jobs were lost in
the fishing sector,
due to piracy and
illegal fishing by foreigners.
One of the issues is
how do we deal with these boys.
Can we provide
an alternative way of life
so that they will not attempt
to venture out onto the sea again?
The European Union
has invested
a lot of money in that area
and that issue is now being dealt with.
And the EU funds, the EU expertise,
will all be facilitating
the pushing of Somalia towards that.
Through its civilian
and military operations,
development assistance
and political support,
the European Union is trying
to help get Somalis back to work
by providing security and investment.
It's the hope of a better life that
might starve Al-Shebab of recruits
and keep young men off the high seas.